all right we suspected this would happen
and now they are being very clear that
it's going to happen if republicans take
control of the house at minimum in
november they are going to launch a
massive show investigation of dr anthony
fauci yes dr anthony fauci who is now uh
what he's 81 or how old is he now 81
years old is going to be 82 years old in
a few months retiring um he is going to
be investigated by republicans
if they take control of the house the
hill has an article about it gop plots
fauci probe after midterms one way or
another if we are in the majority we
will subpoena his records and he will
testify in the senate under oath so rand
paul on the senate side saying we are
going to investigate in the senate
marjorie taylor green and many others
have said we are going matt gates we are
going to investigate in the house uh
rand paul says if we win november and
i'm chairman of a committee if i have
subpoena power we'll go after every one
of fouchy's records now we do need
investigations related to
uh covid and the response we we do
but the investigations we need are into
the lack of preparation
by the united states trump throwing out
the pandemic pandemic response uh
playbook and disbanding the pandemic
response team
uh the way in which medical
professionals were ignored from day one
by the the then trump administration all
of those things do deserve an
investigation and we should have an
investigation into anti-vaxx as well as
other disinformation propaganda content
that was disseminated
investigating fauci
and the reason they hate fouchy is fauci
was willing to stand right next to trump
during those early press conferences in
the pandemic remember i would cover
those
and just tell the medical truth about
the virus that everybody needed to hear
and he was more trusted than trump on
those issues and so trump couldn't fire
him dr debra burks on the other hand
while she sometimes would say things
that were more or less true
uh was very very willing to
um more or less
mold her views to what donald trump
wanted them to be
and dr fauci
gave the best advice that the facts
pointed to at the time it exposed trump
to be this sort of sideshow dishonest
liar who not only didn't seem to
understand what was going on
really only cared about getting himself
elected and trump ended up vilifying dr
fauci and this is another reminder by
the way of just how incompetently trump
was from a political standpoint in
handling the pandemic because donald
trump i've said this before trump could
have treated covid like 911 or like
pearl harbor
and he could have come and said
the amer to the american people
this is going to be difficult this is
going to be difficult for the planet and
it's going to be difficult for the
united states
we have the top experts i am completely
confident in their ability to lead us
i'm going to be deferring to the experts
we will be masking everyone up with mega
masks
and we are going right you get the idea
uh and then swoop in and take the credit
and he would have sailed to an easy
re-election and a lot of people
constantly say trump only lost the
election because of the bad luck of the
pandemic
wrong
wrong the pandemic was an event that
could either destroy you or it could
rocket you to reelection and we saw that
in new zealand and in some other places
when leaders were seen as competently
and efficiently and prudently handling
the pandemic well they were very much
rewarded with high approval ratings uh
as well as sometimes re-election this
could have been a layup for trump if he
sold the maga masks and said we've got
the best experts and look at how
patriotic i am i'm protecting everybody
around me he would have easily been
re-elected and there's a very
interesting article i encourage you to
check out uh let me see what year it's
from it's in the daily beast it's from
uh oh no it's a new article it's called
the four stages of republican
misinformation and it explains how it
works and the article says quote
first republicans use any means means
necessary to achieve power and promote
their
counter-majoritarian agenda remember the
the modern american right-wing
supports ideas that aren't very popular
with the american people the party the
republican party is very much against
abortion the american people are mostly
in favor of it and there's many other
examples that's step one step two they
create and promote disinformation and
lies to frighten their base and to sort
of trick them into believing that they
are being oppressed by the people who
are actually the victims and we saw this
before the doctors are going to oppress
you be afraid of this mandate and that
mandate and this jab and uh magnetized
arms from the vaccine and all this
different stuff
third they create a villain that they
can target and attack
they scapegoat them they smear them they
intimidate them they did that with
fouchy and then the fourth step is never
back down never apologize instead double
down when their lies are exposed and
then pivot towards more fear-mongering
if you can throw in racism or xenophobia
uh that's also a staple and that is how
the republican misinformation works it's
what they're doing to fauchi and it's
going to continue